hi everyone
Sal here from Khan Academy welcome to
our daily homeroom livestream for those
of you who don't know what this is or
what's Khan Academy is Khan Academy is a
not-for-profit with a mission of
providing a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere and over the last
many years we've been building resources
from early learning all the way through
elementary middle high school early
college math science English language
arts and we always imagined that it
would be used in conjunction with normal
physical classrooms or it could be used
by students outside of classrooms maybe
students in parts of the world who might
not have access to materials or certain
types of courses so we could have never
foreseen the situation that the world is
now in but as soon as we saw the school
closures happen many weeks ago now it
seems like a lifetime ago I know for
many of us we realized that it's our
duty is not for profit with this mission
to step up and so you can see here the
resources that we've been putting
together to essentially keep everyone
learning and so we've been doing things
like this live stream which is just a
way for us to stay connected and answer
any questions you might have but also
we've been doing parent webinars teacher
webinars we've been putting together
daily schedules for what how you could
structure your day or your children's
day or students day if you're a teacher
we just put out learning plans so that
folks can understand how they can pace
themselves over the course of the next
six weeks to 20 weeks we ideally think
most people should leverage the summer
so that you don't have that learning
loss and you're able to go to next
school year with as much learning under
your belt as possible as prepared as
possible so that's the goal of this we
bring on guests every now and then I do
want to give a special shout out we are
not-for-profit we are funded through
philanthropic donations we were already
running at a deficit before this and our
deficit has increased because now our
load on our servers etc are up over two
and a half times what we normally see I
want to give a special thanks to Bank of
America 18t fastly google.org and
Novartis who are companies that have
stepped up just in the last few weeks in
order to really make our or support our
response to what's going on with the
school closures and of course our
longtime donors who helped Khan Academy
exist but we do need more support
whether it's an
who was able to give five $10 all the
way up to a corporation everything helps
and allows us to support more folks
especially folks who might not otherwise
be able to afford or have access to
resources like that so today we're going
to just do another ask me anything we
have some exciting guests tomorrow we
have a vice-president from the College
Board to answer I know there's a lot of
questions around the SAT and
implications for when the testing dates
are and implications for college
admissions we're gonna have a very
robust conversation about that tomorrow
but for today it'll be more of me and
Dan my colleague is gonna help support
just any questions you all have and I
know there was a ton of questions from
yesterday we can answer some of those
but happy to take any questions
y'all have so let's see I have this is
one question I'm seeing is so from
YouTube Nikhil NGO vendor says hi Sal
I'm currently working on a project that
requires you to build an app could you
please give me any suggestions or ideas
on building an app well this is
interesting actually if anyone else has
suggestions or ideas for Nikhil's app
feel free and they kill whoever
suggestion you take you know you owe
them a cut and if if you leverage ours
donate to Khan Academy so app ideas you
know it's it's it's funny I'm always
intrigued of people before on previous
live streams of sit Sal if you weren't
working on Khan Academy what other
things would you want to work on and I'm
fascinated by anything that can help
make other people help people have a
richer lives or maybe explore that whole
side of happiness and I had thought
about and I don't as far as I'm aware no
one's building it maybe someone is app
that helps build relationships it could
be relationships with friends it could
be relationships with coworkers it could
be relationships with a partner where
you're able to essentially rate how you
feel about that relationship and then
you can benchmark your relationship
relative to other relationships because
you would have the data on how other
people are feeling about the
relationship so I think that could be an
interesting app if you're in a
corporation or in a school to measure
kind of team health or sentiment you
could imagine in kind of a marriage
setting you know things
that go on in marriages people normally
you know try to keep it behind closed
doors but they don't know you know are
we in the in the bottom quartile of
marriages aren't reading the top
quartile of marriages do we argue in an
average amount or so I think there's
something interesting there could be
with parents and children you know is
this level of angst that were
experiencing normal or is it isn't but
if every parent was rating it maybe
there's something interesting there so
that's one idea is kind of a fun idea
but I actually think it could have legs
behind it I think there could be
interesting apps around just just
understanding yourself better you know
you've seen kind of these personality
type apps but I think things that could
you know there's probably there is
research and mental health research and
things about activities or things that
you can do that will improve your
well-being I think there could be
interesting apps for folks to help each
other either with some type of volunteer
work or a help tutor each other so
that's the those are the types of spaces
that I'd be interested in if I were
making an app so let's see from YouTube
Kate grave says as a pre-service teacher
I was wondering how to implement
collaborative learning through remote
learning and what does classroom
management look like in this scenario
it's a great question Kate and you know
the world is figuring it out and I won't
claim to be the expert here I am I've
actually worked with a couple of
teachers and a couple of school
districts trying to figure it out myself
I've tried to run a few sessions myself
the only tips I could give you based on
my limited experience here with running
real live virtual sessions are the more
interaction you can get the better I
think as you can imagine that's always a
best practice even if you're in person
but if you especially if you're on a
Google meet or Skype or zoom session
it's that much more important to to pull
out responses from the people who are
there because if you don't do that it's
essentially equivalent to a video and
then you might as well be a video so I
would say try to pick out as much
responses as possible depending on what
platform you are using there are
techniques you know you can mute
everyone so you don't get all of their
whole noise and all of that and then you
can call on people say well what do you
think you know I know the zoom has
gallery view which is a really nice way
of saying you know especially if it's if
you can fit everyone on
screen you can say okay does anyone have
a question you know how do you feel
about this you can say how many of you
are support the proposition how many of
you are against it and I think that type
of interaction really keeps the
conversation going one thing that I do I
do this on the weekend with friends
where we try to talk about just you know
how do we become better people when I
finish the sessions and I'm usually the
moderator I go through all of the tiles
on zoom' and I make sure that I get a
response from everyone I'm just like hey
everyone
30 seconds one minute what's your
takeaway from today how is that how are
you going to try to be different or
observe things differently over the
course of the the next week so those are
practices that I've seen work reasonably
well in a in a zoom or Google meat type
scenario so you've mentioned yesterday
about kind of approaches for kids who
are either afraid of math or you know
are scared about a tackling that subject
we have a related question you talked
about the process but we have a question
on from YouTube from shockblast YT hi
Sal what's your opinion on growth
mindset yeah good question shockblast
and for those who don't know growth
mindsets this idea that you many times
folks will have a growth mindset or a
fixed mindset a fixed mindset is you
think you either have the ability or you
don't let's say in math you say I'm a
math person I'm gifted in math or I'm
not gifted in math I'm not that's a
fixed mindset either way whether you
have a positive fixed mindset or a
negative net fixed mindset a growth
mindset doesn't say I'm either good or
bad at something a growth mindset would
say well I don't know how my capability
is the only way I'll be able to push the
envelope is if I am willing to try
things I'm willing to step out of my
comfort zone and I'm willing to fail
every now and then and when I fail I
don't just try to run away from that I
reflect on why I failed and how I could
do it better next time and then I can I
can keep going and as you can imagine
research has shown is that folks with
growth mindsets there's a strong
correlation between growth mindsets and
people who are successful in the field
and you might think that okay I could
get how the under-confident fixed
mindset people they're kind of you know
psyching themselves out oh I'm not good
at this subject I'll never be so they
don't even try but even the confident or
even that's called the
we're confident fixed mindsets also
don't do well so if you say if in your
head you're like I am genetically a
great math person what happens with a
lot of those folks is when they are
faced with a challenge they don't want a
data point that might undermine their
self-perception so they might not they
actually might not tackle the hard
problem because it's like well what if I
get the hard problem wrong or what if my
friends see that I can't do it then
that's going to undermine my self
perception but then if you're not
willing to try that more difficult thing
you're never going to grow and in the
end you're not going to do as well as a
person who said well I'm just always
gonna try things and I'm gonna try to
tackle it and if I fail I'm gonna see
how it goes
and not only is there a strong
correlation between growth mindset and
success in life and I got to say
everyone that I know in life who's done
well in a domain has a growth mindset
about that domain but there's exercises
or things you can realize to build your
growth mindset when you realize that
your brain is like a muscle the more you
use it the stronger it gets when you get
questions wrong and reflect on it that's
actually some of the best ways to form
neural connections that actually helps
you build a growth mindset and so the
way it's related to ever all the work at
Khan Academy you know a lot of what we
talk about Khan Academy is the notion of
having as many shots as goal as
necessary when you go practice exercises
on Khan Academy it's not like you just
do five exercises and you got a 80% we
move you on to the next thing you can
take that quiz that unit test that
course challenge that mastery challenge
as many times as you want and our team
has painstakingly put many items there
so you're unlikely to get repeat
questions so you can get as much
practice and go from a 60% 70% 80% to
100% and our view is the notion of
mastery learning and growth mindset are
hand-in-hand a fixed mindset world is I
got a C on a test I guess I'm just a C
student I'll move on with my life while
a growth mindset will say I got a C on a
test let me try again and that's
essentially mastery learning let me try
to get it and turn that into an 80 85 %
of 90% and 95% so it's it's something we
hold very dear to Khan Academy and I
also think it's a very important mindset
and I have to be frank we all have
growth my
that's hopefully in certain domains in
our life and another domain of life for
better for worse we've probably
developed fixed mindsets and it's good
to be reflective on where we do have
those fixed mindsets and how we can
deprogram ourselves a little bit so
let's see there's a question from
Elliott H Elliott I'm where it feels
like we're getting to know each other
he fast good questions go you always
refer to me as Dumbledore Sal which I
find very flattering you emphasize
brakes to not overloading you yet you
did just the opposite as a student and a
young man is this do as I say not as I
do
how much must want work to be an
innovator like you all right that's good
I like questions that point out
potential hypocrisy on my part or at
least perceived at Bhakra see so you're
right on certain level I mean you know
if I were to at least the narrative I
have of my own youth is that when I was
in elementary school middle school I was
a decent student I essentially did for
the most part what what I was asked to
do and then you know even my freshman
year in high school I was a decent
student but I wasn't I wasn't the the
student who was really I guess you could
say gunning in some way but then in my
sophomore year I started to kind of wake
up to the realities of the world said
well you know if I want to be a little
bit more ambitious I have to apply
myself more it has to it can't just be
me kind of calling it in and just doing
what's necessary so that's that is I did
become a little bit more serious and I
you know anyone who knows me back that
knows that I actually wasn't that
serious of a kind of a person I'm I like
to believe I'm kind of you know I have a
playfulness about things but I got
serious about my life I said you know my
mom was a single mother raised me and my
sister you know she worked as a cashier
at my uncle's food store at that time so
she wasn't making a lot of money you
know she was making around 16 17
thousand dollars a year I was on free
and reduced lunch so I had a little bit
of a fire in my belly to say hey you
know I want to I want to live like some
of my friends whose parents were were
professionals and you know they had
health insurance they had houses and so
that was a little bit of a fire
belly and III do you know so through the
end of high school and early college I
did always try to push myself and I will
admit you know sometimes I kept adding
adding adding in it and it points it got
like maybe I maybe I pushed a little bit
too hard and I'm I'm guilty of that
today too even with the work at Khan
Academy if anything you know it's not
let you know I now it kind of came like
oh it looks all like it's all perfect
I'll just take a break there's something
about the the further you go your
there's a little process in your brain
that says oh Sal you can't relax now
look at how much there is to do and so
you keep layering more and more but then
you should also start to appreciate if
you layer on a little bit too much that
stress that anxiety the relationships
that you have they can slowly break down
and if you're not super observant about
how much you are redlining they can
fully break the engine can stop and so
one of the things that I've learned and
you know in some ways you you often
learn it through experience but
hopefully you don't have to learn it
fully through experience is yeah it's
it's fine too and everyone has a
different redline point you know yeah
challenge yourself that's a growth
mindset keep challenging yourself don't
beat up on yourself if you fail and keep
challenging yourself but if at some
point you feel like wow this is starting
to affect my my well-being it's starting
to affect my relationships I can't I
can't handle this level of intensity for
too long that's a good sign for you to
take it the your foot off the pedal and
you know in some circles it can kind of
be viewed as a sign of weakness that oh
they're not so intense etcetera etcetera
but the reality is anyone who I've known
who's done well yes they might push
themselves they have a growth mindset
they're stepping out of their comfort
zone they're willing to try things and
fail but they have a very good sense
that this is a marathon the people who
do well aren't the people who just you
know pull five all-nighters in a row and
then burn out they're the people who are
able to keep keep keep whatever they're
trying to achieve going for long periods
of time and that's something I remind
myself and that's what I would remind to
all of y'all you know figure out what
your capacity is what you can do don't
and actually always leave a little
that that margin of safety that that
extra flex space to recharge and then
you can and then you'll be well-equipped
for the marathon to speak for it so to
speak
I have to say you know for in even in
college I was very you know I probably
called myself lazy at the time but you
know I I did make a point of making sure
that I had time with friends that I was
getting the full college experience that
I wasn't you know only just trying to
optimize a grade or something like that
and I'm so glad I did it because frankly
the things I remember from college are
much more of the connections I made the
conversations I had with friends I'm my
wife I met in college so oh it's a great
outcome and I don't remember you know a
lot of the classes I took or whether I
got a a or a minus or a B in a class so
there's definitely you need to make
space for it for all of those aspects of
life but good question
and it's always good to call people on
whether they're there not being
consistent in their advice with how they
live so so from YouTube Susannah Garcia
Dominguez Susannah I feel like I'm
getting to know you as well
you can skip a lot of good questions in
light of these health initiatives do you
think elementary schools are getting too
big for example schools that are 400
plus students um it's immature I don't
know I'm not a expert on I mean the
based on your question it sounds like
you might be asking like the
epidemiology of it and if you put more
than 400 kids in a room are they going
to be spreading diseases and whatnot I I
don't know I don't know you know Mike my
intuition there is it's less about the
number it's more about how the school is
structured but but I would say generally
speaking it is nice the more attention
especially young kids can get supports
from parents and and students and
teachers especially so yeah I could
imagine if classes get too large that
that can be not ideal for kids
development or feeling supported and
things like that
so from youtube miss Melissa gutro asks
what is the best way to assess students
during this time of remote learning I'm
well aware that students cheat so it
depends what you're trying to do
assessment for you know we've actually
had conversations at Khan Academy and
I've had conversations with other groups
that are trying to assess student
learning so Khan Academy is actually a
very good way if you want to just
understand where either your thus you as
a student where you are or if you have a
child or if you're a teacher and you
have students have them work on the
course challenge on Khan Academy do the
unit tests on Khan Academy or just say
hey get as far as you can in your grade
level of course or whatever they need to
work on on Khan Academy and that level
of mastery that percent completion that
they are that's a really good assessment
of where they are in their learning path
we've done multiple studies that show
very strong correlations between
progress on Khan Academy mastery on Khan
Academy and other third-party benchmark
assessments so if you just want to get a
read of where someone is I think you
have you have the tools if you want if
you're thinking about how do I give
someone a grade or how do I give them a
score that might impact college
admissions or give them a credential of
some kind then the stakes do get higher
and to your point
there's some subset of folks who might
be tempted to cheat in that scenario I
think there's a ways to minimize that
cheating obviously cheating can happen
in any scenario when you go to a you
know there's classes I remember in
college where you go to the gym and
there's 300 people taking a test they
never checked our ideas so if someone
wanted to cheat they could but as you
know you often hear they're really just
cheating themselves but I think in this
online world we I'm a big believer
actually in kind of honor codes you tell
people like look sign this document you
know you know wow that you will not
cheat we have you on video saying that
and if you cheat and if it's discovered
you're cheating it's proved you're
cheating the penalties are very high so
I think that's one way to do it another
way is I think you could do some light
proctoring even in the social social
socially distanced world where you say
okay everyone if you want to get credit
for this thing maybe use Khan Academy
come on to zoom or Google meat on this
day and I will Proctor y'all and I will
kind of observe you as you're taking
this now it's not going to be completely
foolproof there might you know a student
might have a sibling off-camera
whispering into their ear
something but you know there's there's
no such thing as foolproof but you
really just want to get you know a 90 99
percent solution and I think you know
you don't want perfect to be the enemy
of good I believe most students want to
do what's right they don't want to cheat
and especially even the ones that might
be a little bit more ethically ambiguous
about it they are ambivalent about it
they you know if you have some penalties
if they're discovered cheating you know
we talked we had David Coleman on about
the AP test and I think they're taking
that route they are taking a lot of
security measures but at the end of the
day if a student is discovered cheating
plagiarizing whatever there's severe
cautions for them in life and hopefully
some of what happened with the varsity
blue scandal with these College
Admission scandals it's shown people the
downsides of even attempting to cheat
are pretty large putting you know
ideally your ethics or some your
consciousness your conscientiousness
keeps you from cheating but if you're
afraid of outcomes then keep in mind
they can be bad so from me to pushy
Jane asks hi Sal what factors of edtech
needs to change to help in situations
like these especially to help kids who
have no access to school yeah it's a
great question I mean the big one the
obvious one is access this as your
question implies you know that's not
something that we at Kahn Academy have
been directly be able to do we obviously
can't source laptops and give people
free internet access it's not what we do
we are dependent on that somehow
existing what we've been seeing because
of the kovat cry in in schools
especially in places like the u.s.
schools have actually done a really good
job over the last 10 years and there's
been government programs like Irae which
have made internet access and devices
much more common in in public schools
what this crisis highlights is the
inequity at home is now a major issue
it's always been an issue but this
really makes it stark and it's not just
inequity to access something like Khan
Academy it's also an equity in terms of
in this time of social distancing just
to stay sane you want to be able to
connect with friends and family
over a hangout / zoom session and if you
don't have internet access it's going to
be very very difficult to just feel
connected to others right now we're
seeing some really good programs out
there one of our guests that we're going
to have later this week is Ray Dalio ray
and Barbara Dahle oh they have sponsored
60,000 laptops for low-income high
school students in Connecticut and
they're working with the telecom
providers to get them free internet
we had dr. his sous Ja Ronn from Clark
County which is greater Las Vegas this
is a 5th largest school district in the
country they did a really great job of
first distributing laptops to their
seniors because those students that it's
most mission-critical and then they got
another 40,000 laptops that they were
able to distribute to all of the
students who needed it and they had
partnerships with the local cable
companies to get free internet access
one of our partners at Khan Academy
Comcast is offering free internet access
to students for the next through the
crisis so the good thing is a lot of
actors I believe are doing the right
thing my hope is that this doesn't just
happen through this crisis that the
crisis is the catalyst that makes
everyone think very seriously about it
but then as we exit the crisis people
realize that it's not a just a
nice-to-have
for for students to have internet access
or anyone to have internet access it
really is a prop approaching like a
modern human right like clean drinking
water or shelter and if you if you get
that part solved then I think EdTech
goes into ok how do we make sure that
students can stay engaged how do we
connect what happens in EdTech or online
and make sure that it's works and it's
integrated it's cohesive with what can
happen in the physical environment in a
physical classroom I don't view these
things in tension with each other I
think online should be able to
seamlessly integrate in the physical
classroom but in times like a crisis you
can then lean I like like we're going
through right now you could lean more
heavily on the online
I think there's interesting questions
like we just had about how can things
like assessment occur credentialing
occur online especially when maybe
there's a larger fear of teaching of
cheating how do you connect online
experiences and mastery achieved online
through to real opportunities so I think
all of these are interesting frontiers
I'm also fascinated you know we had
earlier question about apps to create
I'm fascinated by this idea of
leveraging online you know a lot of Khan
Academy right now you could view as
asynchronous which means everyone's
learning at their own time and pace but
one of the dreams for Khan Academy and I
wrote this in one rule schoolhouse is
are there ways to connect people who are
willing to tutor are willing to teach a
subject and people who need that support
it's great that we have videos it's
great that we have as much practice and
feedback as you need it's great that you
have hints and get the solution of any
problem but we know that you still might
be stuck or you still might need a kind
of a pick-me-up or get a little bit
motivated and and it's nothing like an
amazing teacher or tutor or or just
someone who cares to help you out in
that moment so I would love to leverage
I'm always fascinated about how to
leverage technology to actually create
more richness of human interactions so
let's see from from Facebook Kevin
Rodriguez asks hey Sal are there any
plans of adding topics about
environmental education renewables and
climate change of sustainable
development on Khan Academy many of us
in the youth climate movement would be
delighted to help out with that Kevin
it's a great question and it's a topic
that we've talked about a lot here at
Khan Academy you know one of the
interesting challenges is there's topics
that are very current and very relevant
but if we create an amazing course on
that and you know who know you know we
would try if if you don't connect it and
this goes to the previous answer if you
don't connect it somehow to what's going
on through students academics their
schools credentials etc it might not be
used by everyone and so what we're
trying to figure out is are there places
say in science middle school science for
example where these really important
ideas about environmental science could
find a home and and people can
understand the world through that lens
of critical thinking through the lens of
science I think could be could be really
interesting so we actually are we have
been soliciting from potential
philanthropists if folks wanted to fund
that type of content middle school level
high school level science you know Amgen
has been actually a great partner of
ours sponsoring content at the high
school and early college level science
things like biology and and
but we're looking for partners who can
help sponsor some of that content at
that middle school or even elementary
school level as well which I think could
touch on a lot of what you just talked
about so let's see from Facebook Stacey
Rosenbaum asking a similar question I'd
like to see more science and social
studies on the elementary end of the
spectrum we would - Stacey and and you
know so the simple answer is we are
we're always looking for funding for for
folks who might be interested in
sponsoring those types of of courses so
let us know forward any folks and
sometimes we you know we dig into
reserves to try to build out these
courses regardless and hope that someone
will fund it but these are definitely
the types of courses that we you do want
to add on Khan Academy so let's see
other questions here I have a question
from from Laura Verdean on YouTube you
helped me not only pass but do a great
job on my college physics courses oh
that's good to hear Laura how how did
you learn to explain concepts so well
well I'm thank you that you found found
it useful you know what what I think and
I don't know for sure if if folks are
resonating with content that I or other
team members have created I try to think
out loud when I do videos and I think
that what's and and I try to be very
transparent with my thoughts I mean even
in this ask me anything for him is
hopefully you can tell I'm being very
transparent with my thoughts I'm not
being Machiavellian trying to say well
what do people want me to say and what
is going to be the most polished
professionally I'm like okay Sal yeah
that's probably the truth just share it
with folks and I try to do the same
thing when I'm when I'm teaching on Khan
Academy I think a lot of times if you
look at a textbook or even sometimes in
a lecture
it all seems scripted and very perfect
but it's not exactly how people think
and oftentimes it'll skip steps it
doesn't connect it to what you might
already know and when I try to do
something on Khan Academy my brain while
I'm doing the video is trying to do all
of those things and some of those
insights are things that my brain is
just surfacing in real time I didn't
plan on it just saying hey well this is
interesting that enter
in the computer science information
theory version is actually
mathematically identical to entropy in
the chemistry kinetic theory ideas what
is it saying about information you know
just just drop trying to draw these
connections that just might happen in
your mind and I think hopefully when
people listen to that they're like oh
this person is actually here with me
even though it is asynchronous we're not
actually at the same time in with each
other but you're like oh I can kind of
get into the mind and I've seen Pete
some folks who are making lessons they
wanted to be so perfect they script it
out they skip the steps and they sound
very professional they'll say the next
step in this process is when the
mitochondria but that's not how we talk
in real life and when you hear that kind
of you know I say GPS device type talk
are our human brains don't feel so
connected to it so I don't know we don't
know if there is a secret sauce to Khan
Academy but that's our that's some of
our intuitions is that we try to keep it
intuitive we try to keep it very
informal
you know I when I make content I don't
view it as you know I'm someone who
knows knowledge and you are someone who
does not know knowledge I view it as
like hey we're both people and we are
both equals and we have to respect each
other and I might right now just have a
few insights that you don't have yet and
so I think whether you're talking to a
five year old or 50 year old to treat
people with that kind of conversational
don't talk down to them and also don't
talk above them I think also might help
and it de-stresses the interaction
anyway I don't know what we are we you
know we do try to glean some of this
because obviously as we grow and scale
and add more content we do want to get
only get better at some of these
dimensions for our content so it looks
like we're all out of time this is super
actually I might answer one more
question I just saw this it seems really
interesting Sixtus 106 and Sixtus you've
had several questions we're very good
thank you what do you think we will say
when you look back at this time and I
think that's a great question to kind of
finish today's session today's live
stream on I you know this the time we
live in and we don't know how it's going
to play out over the next few months is
for sure going to be one of those times
that happens every few decades that
people are going to be referring to for
decades to come we
are all going to be telling our children
and other people's children and our
children's children about this time and
that our children who are alive today
are going to tell their children about
it and they're going to talk about how
it changed society you know you can go
back to some things like World War one
the Great Depression World War two the
Cold War which is you know it's kind of
over a longer period of time the Vietnam
War things like this people all have
memories of that and how it changed
Society in certain ways 9/11 and I'm
speaking from a very kind of American
centric point of view but you could
imagine in other countries there were
things traumas that their countries went
through that had lasting implications
many of them negative many of the
lasting implications might have been
positive it might have somehow you know
put systems in place so that these
things might not happen again so I think
we will that will be a lasting
consequence in terms of what are those
changes I've talked about this another
livestream I think it's making all of us
appreciate the the things that really
matter more you know we all get caught
up in the rat race of like oh I need to
get into this college and get that grade
and get this job and then I need this
title and I need that office and I need
that type of car and I could use a
little bit more square footage in my
house and then people will think that
I've really succeeded and I could dress
a little better and whether we admit it
or not all of us to some degree get a
little bit caught up in that some of us
a lot to a large degree get caught up in
that and I think when everything just
comes down to your health how do you
protect your family how do you protect
society you know there's people who've
lost their jobs they they don't know how
they're going to buy food next week it
all I think I think it's sobering and it
can be so bringing a healthy ways that
makes you realize that that's what's
important the connections with family
and friends your health that's what's
important there's no reason to stress
yourself out and give yourself a heart
attack over getting a corner office or
getting into a certain school what when
that thing matters way less than your
than your heart health so if I think
there's if there's a silver lining that
comes out of this it reground z-- all of
us on what really matters in life
staying connected and learning and and
and and appreciating what it means to be
alive and be a human being so with that
I'll let everyone go I'll see y'all
tomorrow
tomorrow we will have a great guest from
the College Board to talk about the s
and I look forward to seeing you
tomorrow in future days
you